just some please like that when the
boardrooms
it's that time [ __ ] it's oh
[ __ ]
they a fine wine yes already
no it's great
that is most wrong
you
Daniel here we are for another
fun-filled afternoon with the church
what's happening now as usual we got
some stars we got some [ __ ] reefer
Brad Williams is coming and we're here
Lisa ass him fresh from the Rogan
podcast all hyped up and [ __ ] he calls
his mom and everything it's over
dick he say that listen to what Vicky
said oh [ __ ] it's Wednesday afternoon
[ __ ] June 1st we're all equal
it's a beautiful reefer type of a day
whether you're in tornado Ville [ __ ]
these go where the [ __ ] you're at into
yeah everybody's living in tornadoes all
[ __ ] week I never seen that like that
my life
it's like juvie Israel like Jew Ville
configured calls and [ __ ] up my
connection I need this [ __ ] in my life
comes and I'm just trying to be a good
guy smoke with my [ __ ] family here
and this guy's gonna call me for [ __ ]
directions
I got some beautiful [ __ ] repellent I
might say this reef is beautiful I tell
you could smell this I had it in my
bedroom my wife can smell in the kitchen
its presidential [ __ ] from Sunset
herbal while you're there you might as
well get some stars and get your head
together it's that type of day we don't
[ __ ] around here we don't give a [ __ ]
about nothing to see you there playing
you think I'm gonna be one of these guys
I got an email last me huh what should i
do phone who gives a [ __ ] shoot yourself
if you sent me this email shoot yourself
you do with the [ __ ] one ain't ya
gonna die
listen you ate three stars on your own
you're gonna end up in the hospital
believe that bet they give you a turkey
sandwich I give a [ __ ] hey you go
[ __ ] a little smoke going right
through the [ __ ] phone for you you
know why cuz I love you [ __ ]
little DEF LEPPARD high and dry December
of 81 Mutt Lange you know how we do it
[ __ ] get stung to the gills
podcasting stand up Jiu Jitsu
kettlebells flying through the [ __ ]
air you know wait watching whatever
what you say a muscle swing on them we
always got shrooms in this [ __ ]
it's Wednesday [ __ ] if you don't have
shrooms that's because you [ __ ] up you
didn't plan ahead like the [ __ ] guy
who all rocky money I'm in the beginning
he didn't plan ahead doing little pumps
of reefer Philly right here it's 90
degrees up there let's do this [ __ ]
you're home
you got iced tea you're probably gonna
watch the news who gives a [ __ ] you
already know it two black dudes got shot
unarmed some white chicks kid [ __ ]
got kidnapped and some lady left a kid
in the [ __ ] car thought it came on
90-degree weather that's the news so
whether I have no [ __ ] idea because I
don't live in the area but it don't take
some [ __ ] genius to do weather either
believe in there oh my god
little wiggling here with the reef and
all [ __ ] got a wiggle out of your lungs
this [ __ ] dr. Belize way who you kiddin
[ __ ] uncle Joey here coming at
you the Wednesday direct did you listen
to the Rogan podcast yesterday you see
Lisa ATS debut [ __ ] it is done at one
time he's a [ __ ] animal I'm proud of
him let me day so being sober is over
who wants to be [ __ ] soap Thank You V
[ __ ] something from the peanut
gallery you understand me
it's not about addiction it's about
having fun same-same when I was just
doing a couple pumps putting coke rocks
on people's [ __ ] and eat them it was
fun once I started going home peeking
behind the curtain getting all creepy
that's when it gets fun all creepy [ __ ]
jerking off in the bathroom looking out
the window it's a [ __ ] nightmare
unless you've been there you comprehend
oh yeah how good is this refilling it
set the [ __ ] pigeons loose that's how
we do it the best only why smoke that
[ __ ] mouse weed when the best weed is
right on the top shelf
you over there hand I'm looking for a
deal you think your lungs need a deal
yeah who knows what they spray it on
that [ __ ] horseradish juice or whatever
the [ __ ] you take you going to the weave
store you tell them listen uncle Joey
sent me I want to see the devil and his
ghost you understand me I came here to
see the devil and his [ __ ] ghost if
you can't produce send me to Uli's
recommend them weeds that's how strong
were getting over here that's a no and
don't tell me Lee an experienced he's
been hanging out with me for four years
that's an apprenticeship my lights on Oh
bless you see salut I ain't [ __ ] lyin
but that's it people will have a fun
church play Brad Williams to mind them
and see it
Showtime specialist he's a bad little
[ __ ] I love Brad with all my
heart he's a good guy he was born with
the schizophrenia thing and made him a
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] I don't know what
the [ __ ] well how do you become a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you get some disease when
you're born
something yeah kindergarten they know in
kindergarten when your head button kids
you got a more powerful head Butler the
other kids you're closer to the ground
yeah who gives a [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] Wednesday [ __ ] take
the stick out of the ass who gives a
[ __ ] Memorial Day is over put the flag
away we're going deep into the murky
waters of the underworld bana
oh stop it are you oh [ __ ]
to the dungeon I've been oh [ __ ] I've
been drinking all day have you passed
out by now fellas drink alone thing I
drink my own [ __ ] drink I'm dizzy
it's too bad I wish I could drink like
you [ __ ] Adler's on my half a [ __ ]
when it comes to that [ __ ] I can't drink
I could drink like simple drinks you
know don't get me wrong I would do as in
ginger ale [ __ ] with your world but it
takes time try to a line of [ __ ]
reason was less than me to the wineries
it's a [ __ ] about shoot that [ __ ]
gorilla zoo gorillas are all [ __ ] up
their heads off they keep the good
gorillas food you know Chinese people
presume oh [ __ ]
we're going deep into the murky waters
if you keep the good girls for the
Chinese the Chinese pay top dollar go to
the zoo you want to pay $3 the type of
animals you think you're gonna get I'm
saying you're gonna get bummed animals
this [ __ ] [ __ ] those have oh every
time I go to LA Zoo those animals are
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can tell that eight
was [ __ ] [ __ ] his knife throw is all
[ __ ] up
gets lonely [ __ ] each other normal
people don't do that normal people don't
do that [ __ ] I'm high and dry
people don't live like that [ __ ]
you want to go check on [ __ ] Superman
you're dripping somebody else it's kind
of wet so that's it I don't know what
else to [ __ ] tell you you know I love
you [ __ ] always to the end
I don't little digital I don't believe
them I just don't I respected too much
cuz I get [ __ ] anxiety attack movie -
[ __ ] anxiety attack at this age we
just get ready just lining this [ __ ] up
I'm getting old ugly ugly by the day but
I don't give a [ __ ] don't you know that
going in and makes your life easier it's
these guys that you know they don't know
what the [ __ ] going on they're walking
around my eyes make them believe they're
22 I'm twenty two of my [ __ ] heart
that's it
I read the house I'm an old man we're
gonna have a good time on the podcast my
smoke a couple numbers what you want
from me guys oh [ __ ] Williams coming in
full effect
oh how are you man good see ya buddy I
haven't seen Bret in a long time I was
thinking about Brad this morning this
[ __ ] like a shark he bit into
it and didn't let go
so tune in to the podcast you gonna
learn some [ __ ] late yeah well the
hardest-working man in show business all
right stay black we'll be back in ten
minutes let me talk to my man Bret have
a good day
stay with the church